you know the idea that questions are
becoming more valuable than answers it
seems kind of counterintuitive but it's
actually an idea that's being really
embraced these days in Silicon Valley
and other areas of other centers of
innovation and the reason why is if you
look at a lot of the innovations and
breakthroughs today and you trace them
back as I did in my research to their
origin a lot of times what you find at
the root of it all is a great question a
beautiful question if someone asking why
isn't someone doing this what if someone
tried to do that so I found that
questions are often at the root of
innovation and that's why you know in
Silicon Valley these days they're
actually saying you know questions are
the new answers but at the same time you
know it's important to note that
questions aren't just important to
innovators or tech people they're
they're a survival skill for all of us
and that becomes even more true in a
time of dynamic change I mean we've got
so much that we have to adapt to we have
we have to solve problems we have to
deal with change uncertainty and
questioning is the is the tool that or
one of the primary tools that lets you
do that a great definition I saw for
questioning is that questioning enables
us to organize our thinking around what
we don't know so in a time when so much
knowledge is all around us answers are
at our fingertips
we really need great questions in order
to be able to know what to do with all
that information and find our way to the
next answer if you look at the research
a four year old girl is asking like as
much as 300 questions a day and when
when kids go into school you see this a
steady decline that happens as they go
through through the grade levels to the
point where questioning in schools by
junior high school is almost at zero
there are a lot of reasons why
questioning declines as we get older but
one of the key issues is that in
schools we really value the answers and
there is almost no value placed on
asking a good question
in fact the teachers now are so stressed
to to teach to the test and to cover so
much material that they really can't
even entertain a lot of questions even
if they want to so it becomes a real
problem in our in our school system in
our education system I think people are
starting to address it try to deal with
it in my research I found a number of
teachers schools that are trying to
place more emphasis on questioning I
found a great came upon a great
nonprofit group the right question
Institute that has developed a whole
system of class exercises that are just
focused on encouraging kids to ask as
many questions as possible just
formulate questions and think in
questions and that's kind of the
direction I think we need to move in
it's it's simply a matter of finding
ways within the school system to allow
and encourage kids to think of their own
questions
you